jean michel est allé attendait mais
celle là je vais devoir la lui c'est une
blonde désolé désolé mais je veux une
vraie blonde a mano on croyait pas
reconnu bidal c'est jean-marie data
force et une blanche
ferrer qui appelle son mari au quai au
boulot à l'eau chérie ça va pas du tout
ce que l'agent mais de faire un peu mais
je n'y arrive pas j'en peux plus c'est
hyper compliqué son mari lui du mal et
calme toi mon amour c'est quoi comme
modèle ben je sais pas je comprends pas
ça un copié sur la boîte et j'arrive pas
à elles toutes les pièces elles se
ressemblent je manque sans passer un
vrai bazar je ne retrouve plus rien
c'est pas grave
chérie je vais rentrer on va voir ça
ensemble qu'ils branchent chez lui et la
blonde elle pleure n'y arrive pas je
m'en sors jamais toute seule écoute ma
chérie c'est pas grave tu sais que je
t'aime tu es la plus belle mais
maintenant on va ranger tout lesquels on
est dans la boîte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous les surfaces la blague mais c'est
une petite vanne il va falloir bosser
[Rires]
jaloux de moi je sais que j'aime
beaucoup que j'affectionne
particulièrement
alors c'est pas maurice benhamou à ses
doutes mais c'est moche et certains
patrie c'est moche et d'accords moche et
il a une petite laine petite boutique
dans le sentier qui marche très très
bien tout fait de dieu dieu bénisse
voilà dieu bénisse on est bien et tous
les ans il a un rituel elle marche très
très bien la boutique tous les ans il va
au mur des lamentations encore il vaut
mieux des lamentations 1 sur toi qui
demande à dieu dieu il lui donne des qui
lui demande un porte quoi ils donnent
une ferrari lui a donné tout agrandi
mois le salon et ce jour-là au mur des
lamentations il arrive à 10 heures
tranquilles après le petit déj et ils se
lamentent islam anti cela monde sauf que
là il n'est pas tout seul d'habitude il
est tout cela il n'est pas tout seul il
ya smolik et chouly pareil lui vient où
tu vas sur l'habitude il vient hélas il
importe art lui demande pas à pas grand
chose
et donc là il se lamente toute la zone
et ça fait longtemps qu'ils sont là tu
vois et donc la tam tam ou chine et à
dieu s'il te plaît envoie moi juste 5
millions tu vois ce pas grand chose pas
eu cette menace il te plais s'il te
plaît s'il te plaît à s'il te plaît
allez s'il te plaît aux romains 6,5
millions 7 5 millions pas plus s'il te
plaît envoie moi 5000 et l'attachement
et il est là et aussi pareil islam
depuis très très longtemps et adieu moi
tu sais tu me connais je suis pas 100
euros ce soir je mange je dors cheveux
bien s'il te plaît de jeu il ya deux
jeux en bois juste 100 euros je suis là
je suis bien et moi et regarder tous
d'aressy te blesses jeu normand ça se
passe très très vite
une jeune fille un moment donné dans la
mare est dit est dit moins symbolique
faut pas que ça donne 100 euros tunis
veut se concentrer
[Applaudissements]